[Applause]
well this is perhaps the greatest video
of all time Macaulay Culkin joining
lizzo
on stage in Los Angeles on Monday night
[Applause]
[Music]
just and check this out McCully totally
does the sprinkler
[Applause]
I do it
now obviously the crowd went nuts and
the surprise ended with this sweet
moment
[Applause]
I guess we shouldn't be all that
surprised that Macaulay has fierce dance
moves remember this part in home alone I
[Music]
should also note that McCully is
actually quite musical he's in a band
called the pizza underground now
Macaulay took to Twitter to post the
video of himself writing quote when to
see my friend Liz Oh tonight Liz Oh
retweeted that and responded quote love
you still a mystery how they know each
other but Liz oh does mention McCully in
her song like a girl et was with Liz Oh
recently where we talked to her about
collabs that she was hoping for McCully
wasn't on the list but this one was I
know Rihanna's big fan of yours girl
would know when there's a collaboration
listen we need a video of Rihanna in the
studio period we don't know what that
feels like now so I'm gonna let her do
what she got to do but um I love Rihanna
alright guys that's it for today what do
you think of this Liz oh and McCully
video let me know and for all the latest
keep it locked to all things et until
next time I'm Katie Krauss and bye for
now
[Music]
[Applause]